la détention de klaus barbie a lyon les
passions se réveille invité de ce
journal madame simone veil
les circonstances de la mort au maroc du
général guy me roland delcourt le
correspondant du monde interpellés par
les autorités pour avoir mis en doute la
thèse officielle vient d'être expulsé
les derniers débris radioactifs du
satellite militaire soviétique en
perdition doivent toucher terre cette
nuit on ne sait pas encore où madame
monsieur bonsoir 39 ans après y avoir
exercé ces fonctions avec les méthodes
que l'on sait 39 ans plus tard donc
klaus barbie l'un des anciens chef de la
gestapo de lyon a retrouvé depuis hier
soir la prison du fort montluc en plein
centre de la ville
c'est le garde des sceaux robert
badinter qui a tenu à ce que klaus
barbie passe sa première nuit sur les
lieux mêmes où souffrirent des milliers
de résistants qui l'avait lui envoyé au
cachot
comment barbie est arrivé là dominique
pierre d'importantes forces de police
canalisent et hier soir la foule de
curieux qui se pressait devant la prison
militaire de montluc
tout au long de la journée de samedi
l'itinéraire de klaus barbie est gardée
secrète à 20h15 on apprend qu un dc-8 de
l'armée française atterri à orange
l'ancien ss gardé par les hommes du gign
m'ont alors en hélicoptère pour
rejoindre lyon à 22h25 précise plusieurs
fourgons de police s'engouffre dans la
cour intérieure de la prison
klaus barbie est dans l'un d'eux mais
aucun journaliste aucun photographe ne
verra son visage du linge accrochés aux
vitres cash l'intérieur des fourgons
dès son arrivée l'ancien chef de la
gestapo lyonnaise sera interrogé sur son
identité durant deux heures le bâtonnier
du barreau de lyon alain de la servette
assure momentanément sa défense
dans quelques jours des avocats
allemands
prendront un an le dossier barbie mardi
qu'ils étaient inculpés pour crimes
contre l'humanité tortures arrestations
détentions et séquestration arbitraire
c'est dans une cellule identique à celle
de jean moulin
le chef de la résistance qu'ils tortura
de ses mains que barbie a été mise à
l'ombre la prison montluc est une vraie
forteresse la gestapo le savait bien qui
en avait fait son principal centre de
détention dans la région jean-claude
d'arrigo dix mille furent internés ici
cette pile succombèrent une plaque
apposée sur les murs de la prison de
montluc dit dans son laconisme les
tragédies ton ces corps de bâtiments
construits par l'armée en 1920 tirs
furent les témoins durant la deuxième
guerre mondiale
ici dans la centaine de cellules d'un
mètre 77 sur deux mètres 30 jean moulin
et des milliers de résistants ont
attendu les interrogatoires la torture
le peloton d'exécution ou le départ vers
les camps de la mort
rien ou pas grand chose n'a changé dans
cette maison d'arrêt qui abrite
aujourd'hui une population pénitentiaire
de 140 personnes composée en grande
majorité de femmes et d'objecteur de
conscience insoumis les conditions
d'hygiène y demeure des plus précaires
aucun espace n'existe par exemple dans
les cellules pour la toilette des
détenus klaus barbie fait depuis cette
nuit une expérience qu'il avait réservé
à ses victimes
sur le plan juridique barbie est donc
poursuivi de crimes contre l'humanité
contrairement aux crimes de guerre et il
s'agit là de poursuites imprescriptibles
le dossier sera étayée au moins par
trois éléments précis une rafle parmi le
personnel local de la sncf l'arrestation
et l'élimination d'une quarantaine
d'enfants juifs l'arrestation aussi de
quelques 80 personnes à lyon comme les
crimes contre l'humanité ne peuvent pas
juridiquement concerné des combattants
même clandestins l'assassinât de jean
moulin ne serait pas retenue dans le
procès de barbie si celui ci choisit
cependant de se défendre en utilisant sa
mémoire des dossiers de l'époque les
circonstances même de l'arrestation de
jean moulin qui reste l'un des chapitres
trouble de l'histoire de la résistance
pourrait revenir sur le tapis est
réveillé bien des controverses
isabelle büchler a demandé au docteur
dugoujon comment s'était opérée chez lui
la capture de l'homme qui avait pour
mission d'unifier les différents
mouvements de résistance de la région
qui février 83 à caluire près de lyon ce
qu'ils ont vécu la dernière guerre sont
obligés de se souvenir l'arrivée hier de
klaus barbie force les mémoires le
boucher de lyon n'est qu'à quelques
kilomètres de là
c'est sur cette petite place de caluire
la place castellane que la gestapo a
fait irruption avec barbie l'après midi
du 21 juin 43 dans la maison du docteur
dugoujon nov résistant et quelques
patients du médecin
il s'agit au tour de max alias jean
moulin et d'andré la sagne d'organiser
la résistance de toute la zone sud de la
france une réunion stratégique qui se
déroule pour la première fois dans ce
lieu comment cette réunion at-elle été
trahie et par qui les circonstances même
de l'intérieur
non et la consultation se terminer je
vois passer des têtes l'anah par la
fenêtre là deux ou trois têtes qui
regardait alors je me suis stupide
mendient ben là c'est ni l'exagérer sont
trop nombreux je vais les faire monter
directement dans ma chambre mais c'était
pas c'était pas des conjurés c'était la
gestapo j'ouvre la porte police
allemande
vous avez une réunion chez vous fleuret
dit non mais ils m'ont pas cru c'est
dommage s'ils m'avaient cru sur une tête
changer le code l'histoire alors s'en
sent tellement de bruit sont entrés dans
le petit salon et par la porte fenêtre
vous verrez puis au premier étage lorna
tel remue-ménage des cris des bruits de
2,2 fed les hurlements aux tchèques
voilà quand ils sont ressortis un seul
homme n'avait pas de menottes
oui en bas ça je leur dis ça c'est autre
chose et le transfert justement à la
lavande dur d'ici vont au bout d'un
moment ça durait depuis un an et demi
j'ai été émis dans qui chalon les
menottes aux mains en nous emmène je
suis parti en voiture
alors il ya quelqu'un qui descendait
entend des cris dans l'escalier puis
deux coups de feu sur la place mais pas
su ce qui s'était passé je n'ai pas vu
en tout cas alors si hardy qui s'est
échappé dans des conditions soit trop
long de raconter ça d'autant plus que je
n'ai pas été le témoin oculaire j'ai été
vu que le témoin auditif de 3,4
de là à dire que les conditions dans
lesquelles rené hardy a pris la fuite
sur cette petite place malgré la gestapo
sont suspectes
il n'y a qu'un pas que le docteur
dugoujon ne veut pas franchir qui a
redit à trahir
si c'est lui qui a indiqué la réunion en
tout cas la justice en 47 est à nouveau
en 49 a décidé de la quitter j'ai
témoigné de ce que j'ai
de ce que j'ai entendu je le fais
impartialement objectivement ne pas y
emmener le plus grand respect pour la
chose du vch il ya le procès de klaus
barbie que je suis appelé à témoigner je
témoignerai en termes identiques
j'ai une opinion il ya des
collaborateurs encore à lyon à il y en a
pas ici je crois pas gagné en tout cas
mais ils y ont tous les meneurs dire
comment va se dérouler maintenant le
procès de klaus barbie un procès
historique puisque bien peu de grands
criminels nazis
on tue à se défendre devant la justice à
l'exception des chemins en israël en
1962 et de l'isch cas le chef-adjoint de
la gestapo à paris
condamné en 1981 à 10 ans de prison par
un tribunal allemand
le procès de barbie aura lieu devant les
magistrats et les jurés populaire de la
cour d'assises du rhône
il pourrait être défendus par des
avocats français aussi par un avocat
allemand mais les autorités de bonnes
soulager semble-t-il de ne pas avoir un
faire justice elle-même préféraient
couper complètement barbie de tout lien
avec l'allemagne de bonnes michel meyer
nous explique pourquoi
sous les huées d'une foule de jeunes
allemands un ancien ss se rend à un
rassemblement de la vieille camarades à
une dizaine de ces regroupements au lieu
chaque année en allemagne fédérale
les dieux nazis échangent leurs
souvenirs font bombance et place les
jalons d'une entraide et d'une
solidarité qui ne se dément point
ces sommes sont les ennemis de la
démocratie de bonnes infos riz gibles
vieillards mais en voie de disparition
il pullule tive des nostalgies
totalitaire personne ne peut les
poursuivre car ils jouissent du droit
d'opinion de n'importe quel citoyen de
l'allemagne actuelle il reste que ces
rassemblements sont de moins en moins
tolérées presque systématiquement ils
provoquent maintenant des manifestations
anti-fascistes mais biologiquement sur
le déclin les vieux nazis ont une temps
d'essai mais heinzmann longtemps pris
pour un illuminé s'est placé à la tête
d'un groupe ii
fanatique néo nazis sur la base d'une
idéologie hitlériennes dans les forêts
bavaroise
ils organisaient des manoeuvres jugé
dérisoire remontant jusqu'au jour où l'
on s'aperçut que hoffman le fou n'était
pas si inoffensifs que cela l'attentât
meurtrier de la fête de la bière de
munich de 1981 a été signé par l'un des
ex adeptes de hoffman et ses idées cet
attentat illustre un phénomène très
sensible plus il devient insignifiant
politiquement dans l'allemagne actuelle
est plus l'extrémisme néonazis se
radicalise et dérape vers le terrorisme
et le crime
sur les vingt mille militants néo-nazis
identifiée en allemagne fédérale
quelques 15 cents sont prêts à user de
la violence c'est ce que dit la police
dans l'immédiat hoffmann est en prison
accusé de l'assassinât d'un citoyen
israélien
ainsi si barbie bénéficie jamais du
soutien de la vieille camaraderie c'est
ed arrivera de la mouvance du docteur
frais l'éditeur d'une feuille néo nazis
on y retrouve des avocats qui lors des
procès contre des tortionnaires nazis
malmène les témoins de façon
insupportable
mais ces juristes aux antilles il se
rendre à lyon
de fait c'est aussi pour éviter que
barbie puissent profiter de solidarité
malsaine que son expulsion vers la
france a été concerté entre bonnes et
paris de toutes les réactions qui
continuent de se multiplier après
l'incarcération de barbie la plus
enthousiaste vient d'israël
itzhak shamir le ministre israélien des
affaires étrangères qui quittait ce soir
tel aviv pour l'allemagne fédérale
précisément s'est félicité de
l'extradition de barbie en france si
nécessaire at il dit nous serons prêts à
aider les autorités françaises pour
rassembler les témoignages nécessaires
barbie a ajouté monsieur shamir et l'un
des pires nage responsable de
l'assassinât de nombreux juifs et d'anti
never alain weil il est à peine besoin
de vous le rappeler qui vous êtes et ce
que vous représentez en france vous avez
été déportée quand vous étiez enfant et
pourtant vous n'avez jamais cessé de
prêcher la modération dès qu'il s'est
agi en france d'exhumer un passé qui
au fond au fond de la conscience
collective des français n'est pas
toujours et encore bien assumer alors
pour vous barbie prisonniers en france
jugés en france est ce que c'est une
bonne chose
oui je voudrais d'abord vous dire que
j'avais beaucoup hésité à venir ce soir
depuis hier on m'a demandé dans beaucoup
de stations beaucoup journalistes m'ont
demandé de donner mon sentiment sur
cette expulsion
et puis ce qui m'a décidé c'est lorsque
vous m'avez parlé de ce climat
passionnel
lorsque j'ai lu que peut-être cela
donnerait lieu à des règlements de
compte que l'on allait et jim et des
vieilles histoires franco française
alors je vous dois dire que ça
m'inquiète autant comme tout le monde
peut être plus que beaucoup je pense que
c'est une expulsion était souhaitable et
qu'il faut qu'il y ait un procès
maintenant exemplaire parce qu'il faut
connaître l'histoire et d'ailleurs on a
beaucoup parlé en disant c'est grâce au
nouveau régime en bolivie que barbie a
été expulsé que le problème est réglé on
s'en est réjoui à cause de ça je crois
qu'il faut aussi se réjouir du
changement de régime parce que beaucoup
boliviens sont sortis de prison aussi
grâce à ce changement de régime il faut
pas l'oublier
et il ne faut pas faire tourner
l'histoire autour d'un seul événement il
faut aussi penser au présent nous
l'oublions peut-être trop en pensant au
passé à ce qui s'est passé il ya 40 ans
mais le process barre mais le projet de
barreau l'occasion de réduire en gagnant
un chapitre que les jeux doivent payer
oui mais je crois qu'il faut l'écrire
plus dans une perspective historique de
justice au sens traditionnel du bon
parce que la justice au sens
traditionnel du mot elle n'a pas
tellement de place dans cette affaire
puisque déjà normalement les crimes sont
prêts sont prescrits et qu'il a fallu
des faits exceptionnels des crimes
contre l'humanité pour qu' il n'y a pas
prescription qu'il faut donc rester dans
ce caractère tout à fait exceptionnel et
je pense que si on a pas prescrit les
crimes contre l'humanité c'est beaucoup
plus dans un souci de
histoire pour ne pas que les événements
recommence que dans le souci de
vengeance par rapport à un homme et donc
je crois que c'est vraiment à ce niveau
qu'il faut situer ce procès sans oublier
que comme vous venez de le rappeler il
ya eu depuis les procès de nuremberg
très peu de procès des ss aussillon de
chaalis la peau ayant eu des
responsabilités aussi lourd et que donc
ça ne sera pas seulement un procès qui
concerne la france
enfin la justice française mais un
procès que l'on regardera depuis la
république fédérale d'allemagne depuis
tous les pays qui ont été occupés israël
que en israël on a fait un procès
exemplaire que le rap le procès du chien
a été menée dans des conditions aussi
yeux mais vous craignez au fond et en
france les passions se greffent jeu rien
que je ressens que ce qui serait un
terrible c'est d'en faire une affaire
française avec l'occasion de rechercher
des des histoires qui elles sont
normalement prescrites et de remuer des
événements qui ne s'intègre pas dans
cette affaire là où qui s'y intègre bien
sûr mais de façon tout à fait tout à
fait ta nex même pour des gens qui ont
souffert dans leur chair et vous en êtes
oui vous savez la prescription elle
couvre parfois les crimes à brignoles
des crimes d'enfants des crimes mais ce
sont les crimes individuels mais pour
les gens plus pour les parents qui en
ont souffert
c'est aussi grave ils ont souffert
autant même si ce sont des crimes de
droit commun que pour cette affaire là
donc je crois qu'elle doit si elle a
quelque chose d'exemplaire elle est
exceptionnel parce qu'elle saltel dans
un phénomène idéologique et je crois que
c'est ça qu'il faut faire ressortir au
cours du procès parce que c'est ce qu'on
a voulu c'est que ce n'est pas tellement
longue qu'on a voulu mettre en cause
bien sûr mais c'est surtout l'idéologie
idéologie d'ailleurs dont ils se
réclamaient encore récemment en bolivie
il était resté un asie et je pense que
c'est ça qu'ils font il faut faire le
procès est beaucoup plus que de l'homme
lui-même qui de toute façon sera
condamné à une peine qui ne peut
absolument pas être proportionnelles aux
fesses et toutes tailles qui aurait
intérêt en france aujourd'hui à
exploiter ce procès autrement est ce que
j'écrivais j'aime cette exposition
c'est pas une question d'exploitation
les choses peuvent venir d'elle-même
il peut y avoir aussi des gens qui
veulent exploiter mais je crois que
quelquefois si le déroulement des d'une
instruction peut donner lieu sans qu'on
le veille même à ce genre à ce genre de
dérapages et je pense que ça au trait à
ce procès son sens qui est un sens
historique sa dignité
je ne sais même pas une époque qu'on
juge parce qu' il peut y avoir eu
d'autres époques et mon dieu à notre
époque il s'est passé dans certains pays
des choses qui ne sont pas comparables
peut-être mais qui tout de même ce qui
s'est passé au cambodge est aussi très
grave se conjugent c'est une idéologie
est ce que cette idéologie
ce à quoi cette idéologie a conduit je
crois que c'est ça qui est important
c'est ça qui est important pour les
jeunes et pour pour que dans l'avenir il
ça ne puisse pas se reproduire
la veille je vous remercie le
gouvernement français n'a obéi à aucun
esprit de vengeance en prenant la
décision de faire interpeller barbie
c'est ce qu'a déclaré tôt ce matin le
premier ministre pierre mauroy à la
martinique
écoutons monsieur mauroy en prenant la
décision de faire interpeller klaus
barbie le gouvernement français n'a obéi
à aucun esprit de vengeance
il a eu simplement un double souci d'une
part permettre à la justice de faire son
oeuvre
d'autre part être fidèle au souvenir des
heures de deuil et de lutte par lesquels
la france a sauvé son honneur il faut
les françaises et les français
n'oublient pas cette histoire qui est la
leur il faut que les jeunes générations
sachent ce qui a été alors vécu pour
être prête a toujours sauvegarder la
dignité de leur patrie et plus encore la
dignité de l'homme
j'ajoute que tout homme demeure tout au
long de son existence responsable de ses
choix et de ses actes c'est là encore
une des conditions de
dignité monsieur moreau achève ce soir
un voyage de quatre jours en guyane et
aux antilles un voyage où il a voulu
démontrer les mérites de la
décentralisation et de la prise en
charge des départements d'outre-mer par
eux-mêmes pour assurer en particulier
leur développement économique
la campagne électorale officielle
s'ouvre demain dans ces quatre
départements
pour préparer l'élection le 20 février
prochain de leur nouvelle assemblée
régionale
la campagne pour les élections
municipales se dérouler surtout à la
radio ce soir le club de la presse
d'europe 1 avait pour invité paul quilès
le candidat socialiste à la mairie de
paris
au delà de la bataille de paris paul
quilès a jugé l'enjeu de ces élections
alors écoutons est ce que l'idée même du
vote sanction à un sens cette fois ci le
direct si cette notion avait un sens ce
serait quand même assez curieux est ce
que dans une commune les électeurs irait
voter pour un mauvais candidat à la
mairie sous prétexte qu'il a telle
critique est politique et sous prétexte
qu'il faudrait soit disant on ne sait
pas pourquoi sanctionner le gouvernement
et jeudi on ne sait pas pourquoi parce
que que veux tu ont sanctionné je veux
dire qu'est ce que la droite veut
sanctionner une politique qui va trop
loin ou une politique qui ne va pas
assez loin
qui va sanctionner les gens de droite
des gens de gauche qui seraient déçues
et sanctionnés pour quel autre politique
pour une politique qui approfondissent
les réformes pour une politique qui
reviendrait en arrière une politique de
restauration
moi je dis que si certains pensent que
cette idée de votre 5 sanction est
applicable
il pense tout simplement constituer ce
qui existait déjà dans l'histoire de la
france un véritable cartel des noms et
ça n'est pas avec un cartel des noms que
l'on gouverne un pays ce n'est pas avec
un cartel des noms que l'on donne un
souffle un pays qui en a bien besoin
nos confrères de rtl et du monde
interjet de leur côté pierre joxe le
président du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale
pierre joxe n'a voulu faire aucun
pronostic dans les villes socialistes ça
marche at il dit marche peut-être pas
assez vite mais ça marche
une autre petite phrase a noté il faut
remettre de l'ordre dans la famille
france c'est ce qu'a déclaré le
président du rpr jacques chirac
au mans une affaire sérieuse c'est ainsi
que le ministère du budget
la découverte à 10 d'une liste
informatisée de quelques 5000 résidents
français titulaires de comptes numérotés
en suisse la liste vous le savez a été
découverte dans l'appartement de l'ami
de riche indre asia ni actuellement
emprisonné en suisse pour une autre
affaire d'escroquerie
la direction nationale des enquêtes
douanières aidés par des informaticiens
décodeur ont commencé à étudier cette
liste et pourtant à genève on est très
sceptique sur l'authenticité du document
d'après les informations recueillies
tout à l'heure par lawrence ho et revint
les banquiers suisses estiment qu'il est
tout à fait invraisemblable que grazan y
ait pu se procurer une liste de clients
même si on parvient à accéder à nos
ordinateurs distille les informations
sont codées et nos comptes à numéro
offre toutes les garanties de sécurité
accident ou attentats dans quelles
circonstances a donc trouvé la mort le
25 janvier dernier à marrakech le
général de l'imi le directeur d aide de
camp du roi du maroc
la version officielle veut qu'il était
victime d'un accident de la circulation
ce n'est pas la version que retient à
l'un de nos confrères les mieux verser
dans les affaires marocaines en lan
delcourt jusqu'ici correspondant à rabat
du journal le monde
après avoir été interpellé par la police
marocaine pour un article qu'il avait
écrit à ce sujet roland delcourt
expulsés du maroc vient d'arriver à
paris
philippe chat est d'abord il ya la
version officielle de la mort de celui
que l'on prenait pour le plus proche
conseiller du roi hassan ii elle est
laconique le général leamy commandant la
zone sud est mort dans un accident de la
route le mardi 25 janvier vers 19h30
sa voiture a été percutée par un camion
fou alors qu'il quittait marrakech où il
avait vu le roi pour rabat et puis le
1er février en première page du monde
roland delcourt fait état de différentes
informations recueillies de source sûre
elles sont troublantes
des témoins de l'accident ont entendu
une explosion puis vu brûler la voiture
du général dig
d'autres explosions ont retenti alors
que le camion s'enfuyait on affirme que
le camion aurait été volée que son
propriétaire a été arrêté que le
chauffeur aurait été retrouvé plus grave
encore il y a eu des arrestations
d'officiers supérieurs avant
deux lignes ainsi le colonel boire at
chef des commandos de la garde royale a
été interpellé le 24 janvier ainsi une
dizaine d'officiers supérieurs ont été
arrêtés à marrakech enfin il y a deux
autres indices troublants l'armée royale
n'a pas adressé le message de
condoléances traditionnel hassan ii et
puis l'armée a été placée en état d'
alerte le 25 et le 26 janvier c'est à
dire le jour et le lendemain de la mort
du général guisan interrogatoire on me
posait des questions particulièrement
suspecte et qui me qui était inquiétante
du genre par exemple est ce que vous
vous rendez compte que l'article que
vous avez écrit sur les circonstances de
la mort du général leamy parte atteinte
à la paix publique et au moral désarmés
et ça c'était légère naturellement à
l'acte d'accusation qui était absolument
tout près pour lequel je pouvais être
condamné naturellement pas un tribunal
marocain bien choisis dans n'importe
quelle circonstance à 4 5 ans de prison
donc c'était pas seulement l'expulsion
qui était en jeu et nous avons eu quand
même l'ambassadeur aussi a eu assez peur
il a fallu l'intervention de monsieur
mitterrand et il a fallu quand même que
finalement le roi se décide à convoquer
mathieu morizet samedi matin et pour lui
dire que dans sa mansuétude et ils
consentent à m'expulser simplement alors
que
gt ça en fait un gibier de potence à ses
yeux et que j'aurais dû passer en
jugement est bon par égard pour monsieur
mitterrand il concentrer seulement un
expulsé au liban après l'attentât d'
hier à beyrouth contre le centre de
recherche palestiniens situation tendue
aujourd'hui encore dans la montagne
druze et à beyrouth même michel soûles
aulisi relation à beyrouth la capitale
compte à nouveau ses morts vingt
personnes tuées dans cet attentat de
samedi contre le centre de recherche
palestiniens un attentat qui a fait
également une centaine de blessés à
l'est de beyrouth
aujourd'hui dans la région montagneuse
des duels d'artillerie ont à nouveau
posée les militants druze de monsieur
joumblatt aux milices phalangistes est
aujourd'hui encore un sergent israélien
a été blessé par une charge explosive
il était en patrouille au sud de la
capitale gravité du pape ce matin place
saint-pierre à rome jean paul ii a lancé
un appel à l'aide pour les deux millions
d'africains expulsé du nigeria il faut
amplifier les secours en proportion des
besoins a recommandé jean paul ii puis
il a annoncé un nouveau voyage à la
rencontre des communautés chrétiennes
d'amérique centrale cette fois début
mars le pape se rendra donc du costa
rica haïti en passant par le nicaragua
et le salvador
stabilisation des relations sino
américaines
densia hopping le numéro un chinois
reçoit à george shultz le secrétaire
d'état américain
une visite qui a permis de rendre moins
tendu les rapports entre les deux pays
un signe qui ne trompe pas le premier
ministre chinois
monsieur à eauze yang a en effet accepté
un voyage officiel aux etats-unis cette
année mais les relations entre les deux
pays n'ont pas retrouvé la chaleur de
l'époque nixon mao pierre d'achoppement
principal la question de taiwan pékin
accuse washington d'ingérence dans ses
affaires intérieures en accordant son
assistance militaire à lille
de son côté le vice président des états
unis george bush poursuit en italie sa
tournée européenne des pays de l'otan
qui doivent accueillir sur leur sol une
nouvelle génération de romy chine c'est
dans la nuit à partir de 3 heures du
matin que les restes du réacteur
nucléaire du satellite militaire
soviétique cosmoz 14 102 doivent rentrer
dans l'atmosphère
les deux morceaux du réacteur sont
encore à cette heure ci à plus de 100 km
d'altitude et il reste très difficile de
déterminer leur point de chute
philippe dumez c'est donc la troisième
et dernière partie du satellite espion
mais aussi la plus dangereuse qui est en
train de retomber dans l'atmosphère de
la terre
théoriquement d'après les soviétiques
tout a été prévu pour qu'il n'y ait
aucune retombée sur la terre elle-même
comme au canada en soixante dix huit
avec cosmos 950 cas
quoi qu'il en soit ce petit réacteur
nucléaire d'environ un mètre de long sur
50 cm de diamètre est suivi par tous les
radars spécialisés du monde la
cinquantaine de kilos d'uranium très
enrichi est très radioactif représente
un risque incontestable bien que presque
tout le monde soit persuadé que cette
charge se transformera en poussières
dans l'atmosphère au cnes à toulouse où
d'énormes moyens de poursuites sont
utilisés on est maintenant sûr que les
restes de cosmos 14 102
vont terminer leur course cette nuit au
lieu de demain tout le problème réside
en effet pour calculer les orbites
successives d'un engin finalement très
petit et très éloigné à prendre en
compte le moindre élément susceptible de
modifier la trajectoire et parmi ceux ci
il y a par exemple en ce moment des
éruptions solaires qui augmente la
densité de l'espace et freine le
satellite plus que prévu bien que la
france soit sous la trajectoire à deux
reprises cette nuit
il semble que le danger s'éloigne en
effet les dernières informations de
toulouse indique que la partie active du
réacteur a déjà commencé à se disloquer
il n'y aura donc pas de focalisation en
un seul endroit et la charge radioactive
a donc toutes les chances de se
désintégrer dans l'atmosphère
les résultats du tiercé de cet
après-midi le 15 le 1 et le 17
les voici à l'arrivée les rapports pour
5 francs dans l'ordre un peu moins de
6000 250 francs et dans un ordre
différent près de 1250 francs
nous arrivent ils arrivent et voilà
c'est fait et maintenant le temps demain
philippe dumez et bien vous prenez le
temps d'aujourd'hui vous rajouter un
petit peu de froid un petit peu de neige
et vous aurez à peu près le temps
exactement pour demain regardez notre
photo satellite et vous allez comprendre
pourquoi
voyez le centre de la dépression qui
nous valait tout ce temps variable et
bien s'est déplacé sur là où l'on ne
voit pas très bien ici mais ceci
engendre des vents de nord qui vont
pousser tous ces petits nuages blancs
sur notre pays est amené pas mal
d'averses de neige et de pluie alors
cela nous donne un temps disons plutôt
variable pour demain nous allons voir ça
sur notre carte donc un temps variable
partout avec des averses de neige et de
pluie enfin surtout de neige dans sur
les massifs montagneux quelques orages
aussi sont possibles un peu par ci par
là toujours un risque d'avalanches sur
les alpes et puis sur la méditerranée un
ciel assez dégagé par ce qu'il y a
toujours un mistral qui va d'ailleurs se
renforcer en revanche dans le nord
le vent de nord-ouest lui va plutôt
faiblir du côté des températures
en revanche là elle continue à baisser
tout doucement vous voyez 0 degrés à
lille et à strasbourg 1 degrés à bourges
- 2 à grenoble lui degrés à perpignan et
puis 10 degrés sur les côtes de la corse
voilà à peu près des températures de
saison pour demain c'est donc la fête d
eugénie avec un soleil qui s'élève à
8h15 pour se coucher à 17h56 et à 23h15
hervé claude vous présentera notre
édition de la nuit
une édition musclée puisque l'activité
sportive du week-end sera passé en revue
et en détail demain 12h40 cinquantaine
de midi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain à 20 heures
bonne soirée
à